cela doit être ici depuis des millions d'
années et regardez les Rocheuses qui le
contournent Je n'aime pas cet endroit hé les
gars
respire juste d'accord
nous faisons le paiement je vois qu'il y a
quelque chose ici
ce qui se passe oh mon
dieu  en même temps quand Billy a trouvé
moins de points bon son comment on pousse un
bleu et noir
quoi salut Hannah non tu n'es pas de la paille
la réponse à ce qui t'arrive
est ici vous cinq êtes les Power Rangers
est-ce que je viens d'utiliser ils étaient des Power Rangers
est  c'est une sorte de blague,
nous parlons à un mur, je
m'attendais à un peu plus, donc nous sommes vraiment
endormis, moi et quatre enfants sur le vaisseau spatial
enterrés sur le sol, je suis à peu près sûr que je suis
un super-héros
ku cacahuètes  Les Power Rangers étaient une
légion de guerriers, vous devez devenir ces
guerriers  riors l'hologramme comme un jeu vidéo
il y a un fort hologramme haletant tu es
née elle est un pur mal
comment tu t'apprêtes à découvrir qu'il est plus
que temps nous sommes meilleurs que quiconque n'a jamais
vu
[Musique]
combien d'or est ton
destin c'est  votre temps
[Musique]